hello yes hello my name is Adam Smith
calling from the website of the Nobel
Prize no battle no no congratulations
first are light years how did you
receive the news well I was called by
the Swedish Academy and i was very
surprised i was incredibly surprised and
and they honor they took me Alf an hour
to to recoup from the cross I still
haven't recouped yet but I immediately
thought to to all those who helped me
with you know with my dairy and my
family of course and and also my
crossers and students will have played a
big role in my career and in particular
the person who started here and to lose
the center in Toulouse recycler phone
passed away and probably will have been
would have deserved to be with me today
in this price for regulation and
competition policy yes you work together
very closely but he died 10 years ago is
that when he died 10 years ago from a
cancer and he was my mentor and also a
dear friend here nice to remember him
today then um you're the first french
economist to be awarded the prize since
marsala over a quarter of a century ago
you must be very proud well I'm very
proud in this is true i mean but you
know it's it's also being being with the
right people in the right place the
right moment and you know it's it's a
team work too but it's true a masala i
got the price i think in 1978 or 77 and
and it was a great mind and this is
where yeah it's very impressive for me
and i suppose the timing could be
interesting because I mean more and more
governments are opening up their public
monopolies to private stakeholders these
days so your work is more and more
relevant year by year I suppose well
that has been a trend an urn and we have
been working with Australia phone and my
other crossers to try to understand what
regulation should look like in such
industries
you know opening access to two entrance
in a way that is going to give the
infrastructure get you know built that's
actually a difficult task but it's true
that we need competition that
competition doesn't come about easily in
such industries by definition so that's
why you need a mechanic framework to
analyze it who was the first person you
told after you heard the news well I
told my wife and I told my mother and
what did she says oh I I first to be
honest I far as she's 90 year old and I
first asked her to sit before I told her
of the news sir but yes she was my
mother used to be a teacher French and
Latin and Greek teacher and you know no
lady is very important to us as we're
very important and and of course here
for my wife and my children also I see
my one of my daughter is on skype with
me from London you know it's actually uh
is actually quite quit moving for the
old family of growth yes indeed Oh
probably the whole world are trying to
get hold of you know so I should leave
you to their attentions but for now our
congratulations we look forward to thank
you I'm just okay bye bye bye bye